major Ukrainian cities are coming under
renewed attack from Russian airstrikes
powerful explosions hit the Western city
of levibe this morning Regional
officials say at least six people were
killed and several others injured
initial reports suggest the airstrikes
targeted military infrastructure
facilities but several civilians have
also been reported among the wounded
leviv had largely been spared the worst
of the violence until now
Emma tell us what's happened there
overnight
well uh early in the morning Terry there
were there was an uh an alert an air
missile alert and there were a five
blasts that were confirmed later on by
the mayor of Levy so when such Nola
takes place everybody takes shelter
everybody goes to the bunker uh people
here are really quiet really calm
because they are used to it even if the
West as you were mentioning it had been
relatively spared such attacks but today
five blasts on the weave and there's
been at least six people dead 11 people
injured in the 11 persons injured
including one child there's also a lot
of material damage damage on 40 cars but
also Windows glass windows being
shattered in a hotel in a nearby hotel
where civilians were staying
now Russia says it's targeting military
infrastructure in Ukraine what can you
tell us about the target of these
attacks in leviv
well just like in any other big cities
you are bound to find places which will
be of interest as a target for Russian
military of course the Ukrainian
government is not going to tell exactly
what is of Interest here in the city of
Louisville for uh Russians but you can
also you can think about the railway
infrastructures you can think about
military training grounds for example
which would be of interest as a target
for Russian authorities but like I said
here people in the river had been spared
relatively spared so far and it's a city
where you find thousands of people who
have fled from the eastern part of
Ukraine who thought they had found
shelter here and it appears to not be
the case anymore from where I stand
Emma thank you very much our
correspondent Emmanuel Shaw is there in
live
meanwhile in the eastern city of Maria
Paul a few thousand Fighters and some
civilians are believed to have been
encircled in the azov uh star steel
plant near the port it's the last pocket
of Ukrainian resistance in the city
Russia claims to have complete control
of all of Maria Paul's urban areas and
has left much of it destroyed
Mario Paul has not Fallen yet
the port city has suffered the brunt of
Russian attacks in Ukraine it has been
under siege for several weeks now
Ukraine says at least 21 000 people have
been killed
and those who remain in the city are
trapped without the barest of
necessities
what is happening here in Mario Paul is
expected to soon spread to other areas
to
Russian troops are preparing for an
offensive operation in eastern Ukraine
in the near future they want to
literally finish off and destroy the Don
bass destroy everything that brought
Fame to this industrial region Russian
forces are destroying Mario Paul they
want to wipe it off the face of the
Earth and other cities in the Don yet
and luhansk regions
on Sunday Ukraine's remaining troops in
Mario Paul defied Russia's surrender or
die ultimatum
some two and a half thousand Ukrainian
troops and a few hundred foreign
mercenaries are dug in here at the
sprawling as of star steel plant
it is now the only known remaining
pocket of resistance many civilians and
children are also Sheltering here
with the passing of the surrender
deadline pro-russian separatist forces
say they are now preparing for attack
there are only two blocks of buildings
left before the mill there's a small
area around the factory and the enemies
there hiding in the basements
we're preparing the ground assault the
artillery will shell them first before
we send in close quarters assault troops
meanwhile Mario pulse Defenders are set
to fight till the end
our team of correspondents in Ukraine
includes Rebecca Ritter she's currently
in erpine on the outskirts of Kiev and
joins us now Rebecca Ukraine's president
of zelenski has said that he'll pull out
a peace talks if Russian forces kill
Ukrainian soldiers defending Mario Paul
what do you make of that
that's right Terry just after that
surrender or die order was given by
Russia uh president zielinski came out
and said if those soldiers of the
Ukrainian soldiers are harmed if they're
killed then the peace talks will die
with them but in reality the peace talks
have been dead in the water for a few
weeks now ever since uh the Russians
retreated from areas like European where
I'm standing right now like butcher
which is famed across the world now for
some of the worst atrocities we've seen
in this conflict so far the peace talks
really stalled after that I mean that a
Vladimir zielinski continuing to say
that peace talks were important and that
he wanted to continue them because
Ukraine needs peace but obviously as the
the atrocities came to light it makes it
very difficult for those talks to
continue what happens in Mario upo will
be make or break for those talks as
Vladimir zielinski has said it has been
rumored that on the weekend Russian
oligarch Roman Abramovich was in Kiev to
try to revive live those talks but the
foreign minister of Ukraine has said
that Russia and Ukraine still not
talking so definitely wait and see what
is going to happen in Mario upole
well staying with Mario Paul for a
moment well we heard in our report there
around 2500 Ukrainian soldiers and also
some civilians we understand are are
currently holding out in that steel
Works in Mario Paul what more can you
tell us about the situation there
[Applause]
well that's still uh that steel mill as
you say is a vast network of factories
of warehouses it's been called a
fortress City there's also an
underground network of tunnels and that
is where they have managed to to stay
stay away from the worst of the Russian
fire and the reason that the ukrainians
have been able to push back in this
massive David and Goliath fight we're
seeing in mariu poll it's also one of
the reasons why last week this time last
week a spokesperson for the Russian
military said that they could and would
use chemical weapons to try and quote
gas them out of there there was then
reports that same day that a chemical
attack was used on the steel plant that
Still Remains unconfirmed whether or not
that did actually take place but
definitely a sign that Russia is
struggling to get hold of that last
Ukrainian stronghold because of the vast
network of underground tunnels in the
urban Warfare that Ukraine definitely
have an advantage over
now you're based in Kiev Rebecca but
you're you've been moving around Ukraine
in the last few days tell us more about
what you've been seeing
well kid is the city trying to get back
on its feet despite uh you know threats
of of more Russian rocket attacks which
we have seen signs of over the weekend
with at least three missile attacks uh
in the last 48 hours let's say in other
areas where I am for instance in urban
today and butcher where we've also been
the massive cleanup is under underway as
as after the Russian soldiers retreated
you can probably see the pile of burnt
out cars as authorities try and pick up
the debris I've also been reporting from
the east of the country where you know
that that part of the country is really
bracing for the biggest
renewed Onslaught or a renewed
bombardment by Russia as they regroup
and focus on the donbass region and you
know just basically a massive Exodus of
people trying to get out of that region
before Russia starts bombarding it which
we're expecting in the coming days
Rebecca thank you very much our
correspondent Rebecca Richards there in
irpin